surviving a cement truck nearly missing
their big break and banning jokes about
bacon turns out there's a whole lot you
probably didn't know about the Wild and
wacky Slackers behind Workaholics as the
sketch comedians behind Workaholics went
from internet notoriety to TV breakouts
they proved that they were anything but
the Slackers they portrayed on TV
diversifying themselves on the show by
earning credits as directors writers and
producers Anders home took the boss's
chair for a few episodes throughout the
series starting with the season 4
classic best buds Divine later stepped
up to direct an episode that he had also
written but one tidbit that might
surprise the more casual fan is that the
show's drug dealing homeless man in
actuality was a Show's primary
showrunner directing more than half of
the series Kyle nuicek known as Carl on
Workaholics graduated from Los Angeles
Film School and directed most of the
crew's online sketch routines since the
conclusion of Workaholics in fact his
star is only soared higher newagek has
gone on in the years since to direct
episodes of popular comedy shows like
community and Parks and Recreation and
was recently nominated for an Emmy for
his work on what we do in the shadows
not content with just series work new
acheck also directed The Adam
sandler-led Netflix hit murder mystery
as well as game over man which starred
the Workaholics crew the Workaholics
crew were so determined to avoid cliches
at all costs that they kept track of
pitfalls whenever they Rose by the final
season they had crafted two jam-packed
hilariously moan-worthy white boards of
joke cliches determined to avoid them at
all costs in 2016 executive producer
John quaintons posted a photo of the
whiteboards on Twitter as a public
service not only for other comedy
writers but for millions of viewers who
never ever wanted to hear another joke
involving the phrase quote awesome sauce
hey I love you
dude shut up that is awesome sauce the
boards included tons of cliched phrases
that have popped up in sitcoms but
perhaps the highlight of the entire list
was one small notation that simply read
bacon anything
Workaholics fans are familiar with the
comedic stylings of Eric Griffin who
played Montez Walker on the series
appearing in some 44 episodes but one
woman in Kentucky it seems is decidedly
not a fan in a 2016 clip that went viral
Griffin had a winceworthy confrontation
during a comedy set that the lapping
Derby in Louisville the woman sitting in
the front row had apparently been
heckling Griffin throughout his set
things came to a head when he began
addressing her from the stage and his
Comedy Club employees and patrons urged
her to leave she became increasingly
indignant according to TMZ she
eventually resorted to taking a swing at
Griffin and she was tossed out of the
club just as police arrived for two of
the series stars confusion with their
names has presented some difficulty as
their famous quasi-doppelgangers have
landed in hot water Blake Anderson for
instance shares a name with a football
coach at Utah State this would be a
minor annoyance perhaps but it got worse
in 2021 when coach Blake Anderson was
recorded telling his players that it
quote has never been more glamorized to
be a victim of sexual assault for
understandable reasons the name Blake
Anderson received some hate on the
internet in the aftermath of the Scandal
Adam DeVine meanwhile takes it in stride
that those who approach him often
mistake him for Maroon 5 front man Adam
Levine while some might see being
mistaken for a sex symbol musician as a
blessing when Levine admitted in 2022
that he had quote crossed the line with
The Tick-Tock influencer named Sumner
Stroh the association suddenly required
some distancing with Divine taken to
Instagram to make a lighthearted post
saying my wife Chloe Bridges and I are
doing great and going strong I am not
Adam Levine he's a different guy and a
worse singer we are however naming our
future baby summer Workaholics often
paralleled the lives of its creators and
that was true for Anders home whose
character was depicted throughout the
series as having an unusually
over-the-top affinity for swimming much
of that aquatic enthusiasm was based on
the actor's real world experiences in
actuality home is a talented swimmer he
was on an impressive track when he swam
for two years at the University of
Wisconsin unfortunately his Sports
career did not end well as he revealed
in 2022 on the swimming podcast inside
with Brett Hawk I'd made a mistake and
got in a bar fight and was terminated
from the 10 oh really you're booted yeah
I got booted these days home continues
to harness his talents and Aquatics he
competed in the Malibu Triathlon in 2022
finishing 62nd overall home credits a
work ethic he developed from swimming
for giving him the drive to succeed in
his comedy career
each of the members of Workaholics post
Series has managed to build and sustain
their film and television careers in one
way or another but one of the Trio's
most notable cameos was performed
together when the group made an
appearance in the 2014 comedy hit
Neighbors in the Nicholas Stoller
directed film while recounting the
storied history of their fraternity
Delta Psi beta Dave Franco and Zac
Efron's characters described the decades
past Adventures of their frat
forefathers viewers see the Lonely
Island Trio inventing the toga party in
1930 and then the Workaholics group in
1971 inventing beer pong as a quid pro
quo for the latter appearance neighbors
star Seth Rogen and Zac Efron cameo'd in
a short marketing clip for Workaholics
ahead of its 2014 season finale
long-standing Workaholics fans were
thrilled when Paramount announced in
2021 that a Workaholics reboot movie was
in the works alas it was not to be mere
weeks before the film was set to launch
from its 2023 starting line the rug was
suddenly unceremoniously pulled out from
under the Workaholics boys the vine took
to Instagram to share his disappointment
writing well Paramount plus decided to
cancel the Workaholics movie Paramount
plus told us we don't fit their new
Global strategy we are deeply butt hurt
about this decision because we were so
excited to bring the weird one last time
I'm butthurt that I don't get to work
with my best friends again
fate put Adam DeVine through a
tumultuous path on his way to helping
create Workaholics when Devine was still
in grade school he was in a severe
automobile accident that nearly took his
life in an interview with the off-camera
show he explained that when he was 11 he
was hit by a cement truck while
attempting to cross the street to meet
his friend crush my legs from the knees
down and took all the skin off like
broke my ribs punctured lungs the event
resulted in a two-week medically induced
coma and 26 surgeries over the next few
years the tragic incident that nearly
took divine's life surely changed things
as Divine elaborated on the armchair
expert podcast saying I think that's
kind of why I got into comedy after that
I couldn't do anything anytime anyone
would make fun of me my dad was like you
can't get into fights so you gotta punch
them back with your words think of some
funny things to say back to them the
Mind spent years writing comebacks and
insults and notebooks which inevitably
brought him to performing comedy the
boys from Workaholics spent most of
their days working the phones at
telomericorp telemarketing is rarely
represented on television but the boring
office job helped emphasize the amount
of slacking from the Workaholics
unsurprisingly the creators of the show
captured the real world monotony of
telemarketing from their own backgrounds
while appearing on what's trending
Holman Devine each revealed that they
had worked in telemarketing before
achieving their big break and joked
about how the Betrayal is seen by fans
like telemarketers will come up to me
and be like it's so real this is my life
it did take away a couple of jokes that
made it into the series such as
manipulating the elderly into making
purchases over the phone making the
television series was always the goal
for the crew behind mail-order comedy
Unfortunately they forgot to put someone
in charge of checking their messages in
case such an opportunity arose as Divine
explained in an interview with collider
saying Comedy Central came to us and
sent us a message on YouTube which we
didn't check for about a month and then
one day we were editing a video and we
all showed up to do the edit session and
Kyle knewichek was like we need to
contact Comedy Central and newer check
went on to add that even then they
weren't in a hurry to respond saying the
weirdest thing was that we weren't
excited enough to figure out how to
contact them we waited a week to figure
it out audiences loved the three stars
that are the primary focus of
Workaholics however it was one of their
co-workers that became a resounding fan
favorite Jillian Bell played the office
assistant to perfectly navigated the
work-life balance between the slacker
Trio and their boss Alice Murphy her
placement in the series was completely
intentional for the creators who saw her
as their secret weapon as Anderson told
Vanity Fair we always knew that she had
to be in it she was actually part of
another group and we poached her because
we needed a female presence in our
internet videos Jillian being one of the
funniest people on the planet man or
woman stuck out unfortunately the
comedic Powerhouse that is Jillian Bell
could not be contained to sitcom
television for very long by the last
couple of seasons of Workaholics fans
noticed that Bell was becoming more
absent from the series and only appeared
in one episode in the last year as it
turns out Belle's career was moving too
fast as she landed various and
high-profile film roles for those who
have ever been curious about where the
Workaholics crew get all of their
amazing material there is good news the
boys revealed their trade secret back in
2014 when they made yet another
appearance on Conan I hate to let the
cat out of the bag and tell everyone
where we get our secrets but
internet porno hopefully the trio is
making a hilarious joke but that is part
of what makes them special and unique
the crew behind Workaholics never take
themselves too seriously in nearly every
interview that can be found the group is
quick to make jokes and play off each
other's immaturity in truth that is
where their writer's room flourishes
this group of friends spends most of
their time together trying to make each
other laugh and thankfully that
translates to rip cracking comedy and
audiences cannot get enough there's been
a serious Gap in television content
since the series ended back in 2017.
thankfully the four jokesters that
created the series agree that the world
could use more of their unique brand of
comedy in 2020 all four original members
of Mail Order Comedy decided it was time
for a new type of project that year they
launched their first podcast this is
important the podcast series is not
another skit from the group but rather a
peek at their everyday conversations and
behind the scenes workings this is
important does not cover anything of
real importance with episodes covering
in-depth conversations about warm toilet
seats or the best appetizers from
Outback Steakhouse under the I Heart
Radio and this is important is already
over 100 episodes deep with new episodes
released weekly meanwhile you can watch
the episodes as they are released on the
podcast's YouTube channel
foreign